give you an example of how the left is
just by its own nature very weak on
crime
there was a a guy a murderer who just
got executed he finally got his
his punishment his just punishment which
is capital punishment
the u.s plans to execute a man for a
crime he committed at 19.
scientists say the research on brain
development makes that wrong
so first of all the scientists
say by the left's own premises
cannot have a conclusion in a moral
argument because what the left has said
is that there is
science right physical science and that
you can't derive an ought from an is you
can't derive
moral conclusions from the physical
world that's that's the basis of this
whole
physical science that we're talking
about but what they're what are they
trying to do they're trying to derive
a moral conclusion from the physical
world
right but they're saying those things
are supposed to be totally separate
scientists and philosophers supposed to
be totally separate
but they don't separate them when it
works for them so they'll say yes
science says you gotta you gotta lock
yourself in your home for the next 10
years
because science science says that no
nothing
nothing about science as they understand
it would suggest that it gets more
complicated because
one actually probably can derive an
ought from it from an is
probably actually can derive moral
conclusions from the physical world but
that
that argument is for another day and
that's certainly not what the what the
left is trying to do they're actually
trying to invert that traditional
understanding of things
the man committed a crime at 19 and now
he's got to pay for first of all he
should have been executed at 19 right it
should he shouldn't have been
languishing on on death row for the past
21 years
they should have just executed him for
his crime but then they're trying to
racially demagogue it because apparently
apparently this guy is black
he doesn't look black to me but i guess
he's black so a number of the
the uh articles about this in the tweets
about this have said the us is going to
execute a black man
and the premise of blm is that any black
man who's in prison is there unjustly
because we have a
new kind of slavery and i don't know
they were all set up or something
let me tell you this guy's crime
christopher villalva
christopher v alva bummed a ride from
two
youth ministers a young couple a man and
his wife
he robbed them he kidnapped them and he
stuffed them in the trunk
he then drove around for hours and tried
to pawn the wife's
wedding ring apparently unsuccessfully
he then opened up the trunk
and while they were pleading for their
lives the wife was reading him
the bible to convert him
he shot them both in the head but the
wife didn't die right away
so he set their bodies on fire
and then they died
this is by the way this man would end up
in the in dante's sort of understanding
of cosmic justice this guy would end up
in the very pit the very lowest level of
hell
he committed the worst sin which is
fraud and betraying specifically
betraying your benefactors he asked
these guys for a ride out of the
kindness of their heart that gave it to
him
he kidnapped them robbed them tied them
up
and burned this woman alive that guy
should be killed by the state it is
totally just capital punishment very
just thing
it perverts our system when there is no
type of justice at that degree
when the president comes out i
understand there's a very big difference
between say a drug crime
and a crime such as christopher vyalva
committed though i will point out
with some of these drug trafficking
rings there is a lot of blood involved
there's a lot of death involved in those
too
but i get it they're different when
republicans come out and attack
democrats for being too tough on crime
you know they've lost the threat because
we do not have a problem in this country
being too tough on crime
we are way way way too weak on crime
even conservatives
many conservatives oppose capital
punishment many conservatives even
oppose tough punishment
because it's not rehabilitative maybe
it's not it's not deterrent
they say now it it often is determined
the reason that these tough punishments
are not deterred is because they go on
so long that they don't
they don't actually seem like a
punishment if this guy had been killed
at 20
as he damn well should have been i think
you'd see a
much greater deterrent effect of capital
punishment they're not rehabilitative
i bet capital punishment has at least a
chance of being rehabilitative on this
man's soul
but there is a primary purpose of
our justice system which is justice
justice
it's not just a therapy session folks
it's justice
punitive punitive punishment i know that
that sounds a little bit redundant
retributive justice that's what we're
talking about getting retribution
because justice
demands it there's a role for mercy too
that's the pardon power
but there is a there's a place for
justice as well we've completely lost
that
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you